I'm here today primarily because if I do
not object Congress will have passed
into law a bill that spends nineteen
billion dollars of taxpayer money
without members of Congress being
present here in our nation's capitol to
vote on it
secondly it's a bill that includes
nothing to address the clear national
emergency and humanitarian crisis we
face at our southern border there's no
reason this disaster supplemental should
not have included the quite modest four
point four billion dollars that director
of OMB vote sent to Capitol Hill to
ensure DHS and HHS do not run out of
money which they're slated to do while
managing the over 100,000 illegal aliens
crossing our border being apprehended
and unaccompanied alien minor children
being unable to be housed appropriately
and finally this is a 19 billion dollar
bill that is not paid for when we are
racking up a hundred million dollars of
debt per hour and this is a bipartisan
problem to be honest and it's a problem
that we should solve in Congress rather
than ignore our nation is strong enough
and compassionate enough to have a
responsive and fiscally responsible to
help people who are hurting in the wake
of natural disasters we've had months to
figure this out and to do our job to
secure our border and we now are
expected to let the swamp continue to
mortgage the future of our children and
grandchildren making it less likely they
will in Harran a stronger and better
country with a government capable of
defending the nation and responding
disasters such as these and with that I
respectfully object